do you think the European Union is worth
it or should we end it many people feel
a strong disconnect with the EU while
others praised its achievements
everything considered is its existence
good or bad for Europeans since it looks
like the UK is leaving the EU will
mostly treat it as if it's no longer
part of the club the European Union
combining its 27 member countries has a
population of about 450 million people
making it the third most populous sort
of country in the world it's the world's
second largest economy by GDP and has
the biggest single market in the world
but originally the creation of the
European Union was all about one thing
peace Europeans are really good at war
so they were embroiled in bloody
conflicts for basically all their
history a century long rivalry between
Germany and France alone cost millions
of lives and ran so deeply that Germans
invented their own word for it
f-fine shafts after the Second World War
Europeans decided they wanted lasting
peace that was not based on a balance of
military power instead the economy's
politics and peoples of Europe should
become so closely interconnected that
war would become both impractical and
unthinkable the plan works between EU
members we've had over 70 years of peace
okay peace is great and all but what are
the European Union's achievements and
problems today EU citizens benefit from
many individual freedoms EU treaties and
regulations ensure easy travel cheap
telecommunications a great variety of
goods and services as well as very
strong health and safety standards
European institutions are not afraid to
pick a fight with companies such as
Microsoft Apple or Facebook about fair
competition tax evasion or data
protection through the EU science
programs the European countries became a
claw
engine that serves as a hub of science
in the wider world
unrestricted travel and the right to
work anywhere makes it easy to apply for
funds and set up international teams of
experts with the best equipment in turn
the EU became the world leader in terms
of its global share of science
researchers and produces more than 25%
of the world's research output with only
5% of its population but many citizens
feel distrust towards the EU Brussels
seems far away and untransparent
technocratic and difficult to understand
it doesn't help that the EU is terrible
at outreach and explaining what it
actually does this disconnect has also
led to an ever-shrinking voter turnout
over the decades more transparency and
accountability are desperately needed if
the EU institutions want the trust of
their citizens currently the EU is still
shaken by the refugee crisis of 2015
some countries have accepted far greater
numbers of asylum seekers than others
while the border countries are
overwhelmed and feel left alone other
countries are shocked by the initially
unregulated mass immigration and closed
their borders effectively shutting down
the largest route into Europe the e use
wealth and freedom make it an attractive
destination and this is unlikely to
change the population is split on how to
react to that
some argue that Europe let in too many
immigrants with a different culture
without strictly demanding integration
while others argue that immigration is
not the problem but that racism and
discrimination of immigrants is
preventing integration to strike a
balance between helping refugees turning
illegal immigrants away and successfully
integrating the ones that stay remains
one of the most difficult and
controversial challenges of the Union
immigration aside many more challenges
lie in the future like Defence
traditionally European countries have
relied strongly on the protection of the
US through NATO
but in the current political climate
Europe has to ask itself if it really
wants to depend on the United States for
its safety if combined today the
militaries of EU members could form an
effective defensive force and be the
third largest military in the world that
could save a lot of money safeguard a
European borders and enhanced cultural
understanding with soldiers from 27
different countries serving one common
purpose what about money
well it's complicated the EU created the
largest single market in the world
inside us you can trade border and
customs free countries that entered it
got a massive boost to their economies
even between neighbors trade increased
by up to 500 percent and there was a
steady creation of new jobs research has
suggested that joining the EU has left
most new members with an average of a 12
percent higher GDP than if they had
remained outside and for those regions
with weaker economies and poor
infrastructure EU institutions provide
billions of euros every year helping
economic investment infrastructure and
social development on the negative side
the EU tries to hold together countries
with vastly different economies and laws
regarding labour taxes and Social
Security the cost of one hour of work in
an EU country ranges from 4 euros an
hour to 40 euros an hour
some countries have large industries and
strong exports while others focus on
services tourism or natural resources on
top of this the euro is the common
currency of some but not all of these
countries as the Greek crisis shows this
can be a recipe for disaster
you cannot unify a vastly different
economies under one currency but leave
their economic policies separate so
should all EU countries unite under the
common currency or not should the
weakest links be thrown out of the Euro
or should countries be made to adopt
common policies on taxes health care and
Social Security it's a question that's
been brewing for years and is nowhere
near a solution so everything briefly
considers is the European Union worth it
here is our answer
the EU is very flawed and still needs a
lot of work but it's fair to say that
the European Union makes Europeans
powerful in the world put together we
lead in science on one of the strongest
economic powers and could have one of
the strongest militaries in the world
but more importantly the EU gives us
peace security and a sense of shared
identity and something we all crave in
these turbulent times stability if we
want to protect the values we're so
proud of a strong European Union is the
best way to make sure our voices hurt in
the world alone as small States will
hardly stand a chance in a world of
shifting superpowers what do you think
about the EU and its future in recent
years the discussion about political
topics has become super toxic with sad
real-world consequences let's not do
that if you don't agree with this video
you're not our enemy you just have a
different opinion and that's fine we're
all in the same boat after all so let's
have a fact-based discussion about our
future
[Music]